Oh have brand the broken first of his
name it's official Game of Thrones has
ended and the character who won at all
was one of the most overlooked
candidates for the crown bran the
youngest Stark has no blood claim to the
throne and he never seemed particularly
interested in ruling but if we look back
there were some clues he'd end up King
here are ten of them and here's a
warning spoilers are coming
Bram's importance is established early
on in the series in fact he's a first
major character we meet in the pilot the
first scene in Winterfell centers
on-brand practicing his archery with the
older Starks looking on this
introduction is consistent with the
novels which opened with a chapter
written from his point of view did
author george RR martin favor brand to
end up on the throne all along it seems
likely one particular moment in the
pilot seems significant in retrospect
the camera cuts to young brand during
Ned Stark's recitation of the execution
of just as Ned says the line king of the
Andals and the first men I'm a Robert of
the house Baratheon the first of his
name
it seems they left it deliberately
unclear whether we should focus on bran
or John in that shot that's a tactic the
show often uses to subvert our
expectations for example after hardhome
it seemed that the night King was after
John when in fact it was brand that he
really wanted
based on the night Kings fixation on
bran maybe we should have known that he
was destined for the throne as bran
explained before the Battle of
Winterfell the night Kings Bowl was to
erase this world in its entirety to do
so he had to erase bran first in view of
the show's ending some fans believe the
night king was dead set on destroying
brand because he knew he'd become
Westeros his ruler and a strong
competent ruler at that it seems
significant that bran is also the first
person we see targeted by Jaime
Lannister the man infamously known as
Kingslayer in the finale when Tyrion
makes his impassioned case in front of
Westeros as leaders it's clear he has a
strong appreciation for bran apparently
it's reciprocated because brand makes
Tyrion his hand
despite his spotty track record as
Daenerys is advisor in the events
leading up to this moment it might have
been easy to overlook the friendship
between bran and Tyrion especially since
they've only interacted a handful of
times on-screen but their special bond
actually dates back to the fourth
episode of the series following brand's
injury Tyrion traveled all the way to
Winterfell
bringing designs for a customised saddle
I really be able to write you win this
is some kind of trick why do you want to
help him I've a tender spot in my heart
cripples bastards and broken things
turians words inspired the title of that
episode in season 1 as well as the
moniker of bran the broken that he coins
later on Tyrion and brans relationship
picks up right where they left off in
the second episode of season 8
after the battle strategy meeting
everyone leaves the room except the two
of them
Tyrion pulls up a chair and asked bran
to recount the story of his travels the
writer of this episode Bryan cogman
tipped us off to the significance of the
bran Tyrion bond in an interview back in
April
Tyrion does have a connection with bran
he said Tyrians a student of history and
I think him wanting to talk to bran is
about him trying to understand obviously
brands had a very unique experience this
would explain why later Tyrion is so
ready to vouch for bran in
of his incredible personal journey to
becoming the three-eyed Raven tyrion
approaches bran again two episodes later
at the victory celebration following the
Battle of Winterfell he complements
brands wheelchair saying it's even
better than the saddle he designed back
in season one
according to bran his chair is based on
the one Darren Targaryen built for his
nephew a hundred and twenty years ago
based on the time frame he must be
referencing Darren the second also known
as Darren the good his familiarity with
that history impresses Tyrion who told
Joffrey back in season four that
Darren's story should be required
reading for any future ruler book the
lives of four kings
grand maester Kate's history of the
reigns of daeron the young dragon baelor
the blessed aegon the unworthy and
daeron the good a book every King should
read Tyrion says brands historical
knowledge will serve him well as Lord of
Winterfell but he surprised to learn
bran has no intention of holding that
title at this point it's entirely
possible bran had already foreseen
himself on the throne in which case his
reaction would make sense on multiple
levels I don't really want
if he expected to be crowned king why
would he take on a lordship in Episode
six he does imply that he'd known about
his destiny beforehand as for Daenerys
it's safe to assume brand-new her fate
well before the rest of us in a vision
back in season four he saw the shadow of
a dragon flying over the rooftops of
King's Landing when he was fleeing
mccabe with meera in season six that
ominous shot recurred in a longer dream
sequence that also included images of
Daenerys and of a full-grown drogon in
the sky these were intercut with shots
of Aerys ii and his green wildfire
connecting the Mad King of the past with
the mad queen of the near future the
question is whether branch shared this
information with anyone some fans have
theorized that his conversation with
Tyrion in Episode four continued after
the camera cut away and that during that
time bran warned him about Daenerys
immanent descent it wouldn't be the
first time the three-eyed raven issued
warnings off screen the season 7 finale
revealed that bran had been advising his
sisters about Littlefinger schemes did
he confide similarly interior if so that
would explain the certainty with which
Tyrion spoke to Jaime about the outcome
of the impending battle it's not even
possible that you'll win she won't have
the three dragons are dead she's even
deal the city will fall tomorrow they
won't be in iron feet for much longer do
it if you don't he never ceases again
maybe Tyrion mistakenly thought he could
change the inevitable by issuing fierce
warnings to all the important players
his followers will abandon her if they
know the war is lost give them that
chance if the city surrenders they will
ring the bells and raise the gates
please if you hear them ringing the
bells call off the attack
swear to me escape the two of you
together brands detached attitude toward
power may be the result of foresight or
it may just reflect the state of
enlightenment he's reached as a
three-eyed Raven either way the
hints that the kind of indifference
Brandt exhibits is actually an asset
this ideas referenced in season 8
episode 4
when tyrion and varys are discussing
john's fitness to rule he doesn't want
this room if you considered the best
rule it might be someone who doesn't
want to rule it's likely that varus is
observation made Tyrion think of his
exchange with bran earlier in that
episode perhaps it was at this moment
that the idea was planted in Tyrians
head that bran should be crowned king
what do you think did the show hint at
brands destiny all along or did the
ending feel out of the blue and did we
miss any major clues let us know in the
comments